welcome to the show I am coming to you
today from very sunny and extremely hot
Las Vegas Nevada I will tell everybody a
little bit later on in the week what I
am up to here apologies in advance if
the show doesn't sound or look exactly
the way it normally does we're doing the
best we can with the equipment we have
but I think it will be pretty good I
want to start today by talking about the
difference between an economic reality
and a political reality what do I mean
by that if the job situation is good
according to economic measures but
voters don't know it or they don't think
it's good then the political reality of
the jobs Market is still bad even if the
jobs numbers are good and that's exactly
what we have going on right now you know
there's this phrase It's the economy
stupid I don't remember if it was a
Clinton campaign advisor James Carville
that came up with that or who it was but
it's the economy stupid the economy is
what matters the economy ultimately is
what determines whether voters say yeah
give me more of the same if the economy
is good or it's time for a change if the
economy is bad well one of the main
measures that we have of how the economy
is doing is a sort of two-fold measure
which is the monthly jobs report and it
gives us two elements of data one of
those is the unemployment rate the other
is the number of jobs created in March
the numbers were very good and they were
very good again the numbers have been
good for several months now under Joe
Biden's presidency now to what degree
Joe Biden is responsible for the numbers
it's always a question we ask that under
every president fair question to ask but
to the extent that people vote based on
how the economy is doing this is
happening while Joe Biden is President
3.6 unemployment rate as of March that
is considered essentially full
employment in the United States 431
000 jobs created in March a very healthy
number of new jobs so this should be
great for Joe Biden's not so good
approval rating right I mean great jobs
numbers should help Joe Biden except
there is new polling that shows voters
think unemployment is high now some
voters may think unemployment is high
because there are other measures they
are looking at like inflation gas prices
and maybe they're confused or assuming
that the job market must also be bad but
also there's been a deliberate effort by
Republicans to tell people the
employment situation is bad even though
it's actually pretty good
um so let's uh to be very specific
people were pulled by Navigator research
this did not get a lot of attention this
happened last month and what the
Navigator research poll showed was that
37 of the public thinks that there has
been a job loss in the last year
now
one thing would be there have been
massive jobs gains but some people think
there only have been little jobs gains
that would be wrong but it's at least
closer to reality more than a third
nearly 40 percent of this country thinks
that over the last year we have lost
jobs
okay only 28 believe that over the last
year we have gained jobs it's more uh uh
uh particularly
um a partisan Republicans are extra
likely to think that jobs have been lost
tons of jobs have been gained now we can
still talk about wages we can talk about
the quality of jobs we can say a lot of
these jobs don't provide health care of
course of course we can say all of those
things but there have been massive jobs
gains over the last year there have been
uh there has been a significant
reduction in the unemployment rate since
Joe Biden took office remember when
Biden was sworn in the unemployment rate
was 6.4 percent it's now 3.6 percent it
hasn't quite been halved but pretty damn
close and this is all this is two things
this is partially people just don't know
what's going on partially people might
be saying well if inflation is so high
then probably the job market is bad but
Republicans have actually been saying
the job situation is terrible
uh we played one clip on yesterday's
show
representative Republican representative
Republican congresswoman Lisa McLean we
played some clips of her speaking at the
uh Trump rally in Michigan and she said
unemployment is at a 40-year high
remember this clip we went from an
economy that was booming
to a shambles what we have now is a
shambles it's a complete mess
unemployment 40-year High labor shortage
we can't find Goods at the store so of
course the truth is that unemployment is
extremely low and it is significantly
lower than it was when Donald Trump left
office so at the end of of the day
this is about two things one does Joe
Biden need accomplishments yes I mean
listen
Trump lost in 2020 he barely lost but
part of the reason he lost was he lacked
accomplishments he said he would do a
wall and he didn't he said he would
replace Obamacare with something
beautiful and he didn't he said he would
beat covid and he didn't he didn't have
accomplishments so do you need
accomplishments it helps to have them
you can just claim them but it helps to
actually have accomplishments but if the
voters don't know
that the reality is the reality they're
going to vote for someone else and so I
don't know who to blame for this but the
jobs Market is good
and many Republicans think jobs have
been lost and nearly 40 percent of
Americans think jobs have been lost
something has to be done in order for
this to lead to anything other than
Democratic disaster in November of 2022
now just uh what six and a half months
away I don't exactly know what the
solution is but these are basic facts
basic facts
I want to go back because we're talking
about economics I want to go back to
something I've been telling you about
for a decade at this point in time there
are now more sort of mainstream media
Outlets taking this topic seriously if
you go back a really long time
certainly 50 years you can go back 80.
it starts to become less useful if you
go beyond When the Party's switched but
if you go back 50 years
when you have a Democratic president in
the White House job growth does better
people's income and income growth does
better and GDP growth does better now as
always there is no one there are no two
or three metrics which tell you
everything you need to know about how an
economy is doing you could say but we
need to look at wages labor
participation inflation all these
different things consumer confidence
sure but jobs income and GDP all taken
together are well accepted metrics of
how an economy is doing and they all do
better on average when the president is
a Democrat I am thrilled and we're
linking to this article that Newsweek is
finally talking about this they write
nearly all major U.S economic indicators
including income productivity stock
prices jobs and domestic product show
growth under democratic presidents
compared to when repub Republicans are
in the White House I'm not going to give
you all the data again because we've
given it to you so many times if you had
the choice going back between saying do
I want to be in the job market when
there's a democrat in the white house or
a republican statistically you would
have been better off when there's a
democrat in the white house if you had
said I'm going to invest in the S P 500
when there's a democrat in the white
house or a republican if you could pick
only the years that one or the other is
in the White House your investment
return would be dramatically better if
you had invested only in the Democratic
years now remember that stocks in
general tend to go up so you would have
done okay in either case but you would
have done better
when there was a Democratic president in
the White House the New York Times
released an analysis on this and the
economy does better when Democrats are
President by every single metric now
whenever this is presented whenever this
fact is presented and it is a fact
you might not like it you might want to
explain it away but it is a fact we hear
many arguments against one of the
arguments we hear is David you're
looking at the wrong thing
those metrics did better
because it was a republican-controlled
house or a republican-controlled senate
or both and the answer is no there is no
clear partisan pattern
when you look at control of the house
and control of the Senate other than it
sometimes matches what is going on in
the Oval Office
that's not a good argument next argument
that's often made is Democrats just get
lucky you know what happens Republicans
have these recessions and they fix them
and then they leave office and then in
comes a Democratic president and they
get all the credit for what a republican
did and there's two answers to that the
first answer to that is okay let's
pretend that what you're saying is true
let's give the first six months of any
one president's economic growth to the
last guy so in other words what that
would mean is Barack Obama's first six
months will give to George W bush give
George W bush a little bit of the credit
for the Obama recovery
it still favors Democrats so even if you
kind of put in place a six-month grace
period the numbers still don't look much
better for Republicans but maybe the
most important thing about this is if
it's true that Democrats are coming in
and experiencing economic recoveries
when they are in the White House
why are there so many republican
recessions that have to be fixed during
Democratic Administration so the
analysis is extraordinarily clear it's a
well-known phenomenon and yet this is
why you know we we opened the show today
by saying
economic reality
political reality you might have an
economic reality politically it doesn't
exist unless people believe it and much
the same way there's this it's really a
meme at this point it's a self it almost
spreads virally there's this idea
that Republicans are better stewards of
the economy there are no statistical
uh uh sets of data that you can point to
in which that is the case let me know
via Twitter you can find me at dpacman
why does this talking point about
Republicans being good for the economy
persist so strongly because it does find
me on Twitter let me know also just a
quick reminder Tuesday April 19th 6 PM
Eastern is the next David pakman show
Town Hall it will be streaming live on
Pac-Man Live all are welcome uh that's
April 19th 6 p.m looking forward to
seeing and hearing from many of you
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David packman show truly genuinely
depends on your support to do what we do
we're a community
funded program people who listen to the
show and get a membership or people who
watch some YouTube clips people who
maybe listen to us on one of our radio
Affiliates or just getting the podcast
on our website every single day we
depend on your support and the best way
the most direct way to support what we
do is to sign up at joinpakman.com we do
an extra show every day for our members
you also have the ability to gift a
membership to someone else if you don't
have anyone to gift a membership to
that's okay I now have a list of six 615
people who have asked for memberships
and uh you can donate a membership to
one of them simply by checking the Box
this is a gift when you sign up and not
sending it to anyone it will then be
left to me and believe me I have a few
hundred people who would love to get a
membership from you I want to talk to
you today about what I'm calling the
Nexus the intersection
of immoral and stupid
and when I hear the Nexus of immoral and
stupid
I think about a handful of members of
Congress and on that list is Republican
Matt Gates Matt Gates is voting against
capping insulin prices to the end user
now it's crazy to use the term end user
when we're talking about medicine I
agree with you it's also a crazy
situation because we are only talking
about capping the price of insulin for
the end user so late last week the House
of Representatives passed a democratic
sponsored Bill to cap insulin at 35 a
month for most Americans in terms of
their out of pocket now of course you
know and I know and anybody who's dealt
with health insurance knows these things
cost way more but health insurance will
pay part of it and then there's a
discount and blah blah blah blah I I
know some of you were sick of this
example but it's been at least six
months since since I've made an example
when I had my Infamous appendectomy me
you might remember that the sticker
price was 35 Grand now that's what the
hospital billed my insurance my
insurance had said sirs and mams at the
hospital we know people sometimes have
appendicitis will you contract with us
for appendectomies for I believe it was
eleven thousand dollars so of the thirty
something thousand that the hospital
wanted
my insurance said we are okay with 11
and I had a two thousand dollar
deductible so the thirty five thousand
dollar appendectomy ended up being two
thousand for me and my insurance made up
that other nine thousand dollars
similarly with insulin you know there
are people now who pay over a thousand
dollars a month in the price the actual
price of insulin MSRP sticker price
wouldn't even change with this bill but
the point here is insulin guys insulin
thirty five dollars a month let's cap it
and Matt Gates says no why does Matt
Gates say no basically because people
should just lose weight he wrongly
thinks not that it would really make a
big difference but he wrongly thinks
only overweight people need insulin Matt
Matt Gates sang quote
while Democrat posturing of H.R 6833
victimizes insulin pays as people with
an uncontrollable disease that are being
taken advantage of and need big brother
to throw them a raft lifestyle changes
and mass would expeditiously lower
demand and the subsequent prices of
insulin 90 to 95 percent of people with
diabetes have type 2 which can be
prevented or delayed with healthy
lifestyle changes such as losing weight
eating healthy food and being active
arbitrary price controls are no
substitute for individual weight control
since 2000 the number of diabetes cases
in the U.S has nearly doubled the demand
for insulin has increased and the
requisite price increase has followed
suit in other words the price of insulin
increases as waistlines increase so yes
he's a prick yes of course but he's also
ignorant aside from this being asinine
and disgusting and just horrible it's
not accurate type 1 diabetes is managed
by taking insulin to control blood sugar
type 2 diabetes in more ways than type 1
is managed in other ways this means
medication this means exercise this
means diet when I say medication I mean
a pill not insulin people with type 2
diabetes sometimes are prescribed
insulin but insulin is about type 1
diabetes insulin is for type 1 diabetes
who are often perfectly fit it is for
type 1 diabetes for people who are not
overweight and there's a couple of
different things here and I don't even
know where to start to be totally honest
guys I mean on the one hand
should absolutely no condition related
to our own actions be covered because
then we're saying we're not covering
lung cancer most of which is related to
cigarette smoking
we're not covering injuries that happen
as a result of what we might call
extreme sports or risky activities we're
not covering covet stays for people who
are unvaccinated I mean so first of all
is the is this idea that I mean listen I
want people to live as healthy a
lifestyle as possible but are we really
saying we shouldn't be covering costs
for people who have certain conditions
because of how those conditions develop
that seems very very dangerous number
now as I've said before people will say
but David sir didn't you say that
if we have a full ER
and you need to start putting coveted
patients on ventilators it seems okay as
part of triaging limited resources to
say the vaccinated people get the
ventilator first because they're more
likely to survive and they're more
likely to follow medical directions as
to their care that is different than
saying you're just not covered if you
have type 2 diabetes so that's number
one number two you know we've talked
before about obesity seen as a basically
a moral failing so putting aside that
insulin is mostly for type 1 and Matt
Gates is talking about type 2.
this idea that we can only see we should
only see obesity as a moral failing is
uh is wrong at the same time it should
be okay to say that in the United States
lack of uh nutritional education leads
people to eat persistently unhealthy
diets for their entire lives and we've
got to be able to talk about that as
well but when we talk about obesity
we're talking about sometimes diet
sometimes genetic factors sometimes
underlying disease there's a lot of
different things and again seeing
obesity as the big moral failing also is
extraordinarily myopic so uh and and the
fat shaming and stuff like that does not
appear to work Matt Gates is disgusting
insulin should be cheap to the end user
maybe we call them the End customer or
whatever the case may be uh and he's
vile for voting against this and he's
vile for his reasoning as well uh we
have been man this is this is really bad
we have been talking about how
the modern
reactionary movement I don't call them
conservative there's nothing
conservative about them the modern
reactionary trumpian movement
is dangerous and we learned that
when they kidnapped the governor of
Michigan attempted to kidnap the
governor of Michigan sorry correction we
learned that when they did all the
things they did on January 6. these
These are dangerous people
and there is a man who posted videos to
tick tock
showing himself hunting for quote
non-binaries non-binaries by which I
imagine he meant
people who identify from a gender
standpoint as non-binary or transgender
that's my understanding of what this guy
meant Tick Tock has removed the videos
but it's been widely downloaded and we
have it and we're going to look at the
video and it is going to be disturbing
not because there's any gory images or
anything like that but it's disturbing
because it is another reminder of how
dangerous these people are
this man
shows himself carrying out what he calls
a snipe hunt demanding non-binaries
be turned over to him
okay
and he says if he finds people meeting
his criteria
he will load them into the back of his
vehicle transport them presumably
against their will which we would call
kidnapping he doesn't say they're going
to want to come with me
and he would bring them to a hospital
for treatment
this would be very illegal let's take a
look at the first video as if we need
like the extra details he's wearing an F
Joe Biden hoodie in the video as well
take a look at this the man I guess goes
by the handle steel Walker 42 live and
believes he's doing the Lord's work take
a look at this this may come off a
little transphobic but it's not it's not
I'm doing lore's work I'm trying to help
people I'm here to get all the
non-binaries I'm at the Motel 6 right
now we're starting here and we're gonna
get all the non-binaries picked up put
them in the back of my truck and we're
gonna take them
two hospitals if you have any non-biners
here I'm shutting this [ __ ]
I'm shutting this whole operation
any non-binary
anything you ready to go sir we're going
to get all the non-binaries let's go I
bet I need to get in the back either way
all right we're going to get all the
non-binaries right now if you see a
non-binary
snatch them up if you got any
non-binaries I got to pick them up and I
got to take them you don't need to see
my ID I need to see where them all
Finance so I don't understand where
they're hiding are they [ __ ]
camouflage they got that binary
camouflage
are there any non-binaries in this hotel
because because that's a problem right
there we got some let me out
he's asking about
where the non-binaries
this is Terrorism
this is Terrorism you know I stopped
short the other day
of saying certain things we were looking
at our terrorism because I'm not sure
this is Terrorism this is going out
there and saying based on your
membership in a group the group would be
trans non-binary I guess everything that
falls under that umbrella this guy
doesn't like and saying we're going to
round you up and we're going to take you
in now he's not saying we're gonna kill
you he seems to at least have the common
sense to know that would be even more
too far so he says we're going to take
you to treatment at a hospital this guy
has previously posted videos encouraging
others to quote go hunting and implied
that those who identify as non-binary
should be shot here's the second video
then if you want to go hunting
get out get out into the
Woods and you can you'll see a lot of
knobs running around
everywhere just jaw jacking
indoctrinating everything the wildlife
catch them hoes so
good for tick tock for pulling it down
this is not freeze free it's free speech
you're threatening crimes here
a number of different crimes that's
number one
but this is scary
the I can't even imagine if I was trans
or non-binary or had anything other than
what this guy sees as the acceptable
identity traits I would be scared
I would be scared and to be perfectly
Frank we were talking about this on our
live stream over the weekend I don't
know if the solution would be
flood the red states with progressives
to sort of like push these people out or
at least make them not want to go out
and do this stuff or is the solution to
get the progressive the hell out of
these places and get people who are
lgbtq plus out of these places for their
own safety I don't know I don't know the
solution
but this is extraordinarily disturbing
and it is difficult to think
as someone who's not part of these
groups
it's really difficult for me to imagine
the the terror
that folks must be going through when
guys like that are around hopefully
police are investigating I don't know
for sure I will find out and let you
know we'll have these clips if you're
only listening today and you have a sort
of morbid curiosity about what the guy
looks like and what he's doing we'll
have these clips up on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
we'll take a very quick break and be
right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Greg
Tucker Kellogg who's a biology professor
at the National University of Singapore
he also has a YouTube channel addressing
scientific misinformation on social
media of which there is a lot right now
a great really great to have you on Greg
I appreciate it
well thanks thanks for having me so I
want to eventually work towards
Ivermectin which you've been talking
about quite a bit on your channel but
maybe first we could talk a little bit
about you know since the early days in
the pandemic there there have been these
kind of clusters of
um
uh
uh treatment ideas that are proposed and
I want to be careful how I how I
describe them because just because
something is proposed as a treatment
doesn't mean it is a treatment for covid
and early on it was
hydroxychloroquine
azithromycin maybe vitamin D although
vitamin D was I think proposed more
prophylactically than some of these
other things and eventually Ivermectin
was added to the list generally speaking
my idea has been that most of the
proposed so-called treatments are cheap
ubiquitous things which are mostly
available in much of the world and that
so in some sense it makes sense that we
would at least ask might these things be
you be useful is that a fair assessment
of how some of these things start
absolutely so there's a whole area of
drug Discovery and Drug development uh
that's referred to as drug repurposing
and so the idea is to take drugs that
are available for other purposes and to
see if they can be basic well repurposed
and and found utility in something like
an emergency like covid and so there
were lots of tests around the world and
actually large screening programs there
was a fairly large screening program at
the NIH for example that was screening
through approved drugs to see whether
they would have activity in various
viral assays and those screening
programs eventually you know they
generated some interest and there were
some follow-ups but yeah there's there's
a lot of interest in seeing whether some
of those things can be can be used and
of course steroid treatments are now a
Mainstay of of treatment for for
covid-19 so some of that has been really
really useful when this is done our our
really expensive drugs sometimes tested
and what I mean by that is I haven't
heard of expensive cancer drugs being
tested to see might that work for covid
for example I mean is it typically the
cheap stuff
um well it's typically everything that's
approved because one of the one of the
things one would like to be able to do
with a drug in particular is to be able
to skip the the safety trials so if you
know if you already know that it's safe
then that's fine but actually in the
case of cancer you know a lot of
traditional Cancer drugs are like
chemotherapeutics are effectively
poisonous and so it's not so much the
price but you know there are other
reasons not to give them to something to
say a coveted patient
so in terms of the appropriate way to
determine whether a drug Works to treat
a disease like covid in the last two
years we've seen every iteration from a
French doctor gave hydroxychloroquine to
38 people and here's sort of like his
sense of how they did all the way to
some actual randomized controlled trials
for Ivermectin comparing it to the
standard of care versus a placebo Etc so
talk a little bit about sort of like the
ideal formulation of the way we would
test something for covid
um sure well I I'll speak to like the
drug Discovery and clinical trial
aspects of it so when one does you know
drug Discovery when one does uh clinical
trials you you like to uh to to treat or
to test new drugs or drugs for a new
purpose in a way that is relevant so
sometimes it might be pre-clinical
studies
um screening for large numbers and then
as you get to more expensive studies
like clinical trials you move to smaller
groups so there's uh some of the most
important trials in this have been what
they call platform trials where they're
looking at a large number of different
agents so the together trial for example
um is such a platform trial and they
look at a number of Agents there's been
some really good things that have come
out with this but it's not just you know
it's not just everything in the kitchen
sink you have to you know make choices
judiciously with the evidence that you
have and move forward with the things
that have the most promise in general
when we have now when we're 2 years in
to this pandemic there is somewhat of an
accepted standard of care for how
moderate to severe covid is treated in
hospital settings so if we want to
introduce the idea of measuring the
effect of something like Ivermectin
would we always be testing it against
the standard of care rather than against
nothing because few people would just
get nothing is that an important aspect
of this yeah so in um right so in
clinical trials there's there's a
principle of equipoise where you you
don't want to give an inferior treatment
you know ethically you want to know that
you're giving at least the standard of
care obviously if there is no standard
of care then that's another situation
but if you have a standard of care you
want to be giving it uh also of course
as over the last year as a lot of people
have gotten vaccinated and as people
have had prior infections so there's
some protection from immunity and that
also complicates trials there's lots of
things that complicate trials over time
but certainly you want to give you you
don't want to deny the standard of care
to somebody in a clinical trial and
again in an ideal formulation with
something like Ivermectin would you
really want three groups one group that
is just the standard of Care Group and
everybody knows they're not receiving
Ivermectin and then you would have a
placebo group and an Ivermectin group
and they don't know whether they are
receiving the Ivermectin is that was
would that be the ideal setup
so in the in the first case which are
talking about where you know people know
you know so it's generally two groups
it's two arms in in one particular
setting even of a platform trial so in a
platform trial I might be looking at
multiple different settings
um but you want to be able to compare
the people who are getting the standard
of care and the people who are getting
the standard of care and then maybe some
new agent Fair a few weeks ago you did a
great interview with Jacob effemenko
about a study or conference abstract as
maybe it's better referred to on
Ivermectin I did a much less detailed a
set segment on that and this was one
that really caught fire everybody from
Jordan Peterson to uh Dr John Campbell
who I I don't say this pejoratively he's
not a medical doctor I I just I feel
driven to say that because there's some
confusion about about his credentials
initially said wow 70 reduction in
mortality for people given Ivermectin
you EXT extensively broke that down
including with one of the authors of the
conference abstract who said this was
retrospective observational data we
don't know about dosing the groups
weren't separated by vaccine status
there's all these other problems with
this why do you think that caught such
fire on social media because the result
was just notable and it made a great
headline
yeah so
um I mean I'm learning a lot about how
this misinformation
train works and Ivermectin seems to be
the grift that keeps on grifting and uh
so what happens is in this case it was
just a conference abstract that had this
kind of startling result or a result
that could be spun in a way that was
startling and seemed dramatic and so
that little thing gets Amplified into
something much larger and then
the results that are presented in the
cons in the conference abstract were
then taken way out of context and
misrepresented in in other ways and
all the limitations of the conference
abstract which led to it not being
published they weren't talked about and
so it just seemed like it was something
much much larger much more definitive
than it was and that is what keeps
happening over and over again I uh have
no you know I think one of the sad
things about this is it's very easy to
say this stuff has become politicized
and and in a certain sense it it has but
I'm not aware of people who don't want
Ivermectin or hydroxychloroquine or is
it the Z packs to work I mean it I would
love it if we had evidence that
something really cheap and widely
available was effective so I feel like
it's it's not uniformly or symmetrically
politicized I just want to be able to
say we have or we don't have evidence
that this works but it really does seem
particularly here in the United States
that there are people who attach to any
one of these ideas and they almost stop
caring about what the data show
yeah so it's it's frustrating so I'm not
a medical doctor either I'm a scientist
I'm a I'm a biologist a biophysicist by
training yes and the uh it's it's
frustrating because
what's happening in in this case is that
people are latching onto these and then
they're they're latching on to things
that have not been shown to be effective
instead of
moving forward with things that are
effective that have been shown to be
effective and that's the real tragedy of
this because they keep latching onto it
and I think it's actually not just I
wouldn't say it's a failure of science
so in the case of fameco it was not a
failure of science science worked they
decided not to publish the paper but it
was a terrible failure of science
communication and that's what keeps
happening so the the the misuse tends to
exploit the ignorance
of people about how science
communication works and kind of widens
that Gap so people don't know what a
conference abstract is and then they
take that lack of knowledge the public
lack of knowledge and just
you know
build on it
in thinking back now to that earlier
list that I mentioned of the ideas that
there were early in the pandemic and if
you're not prepared to go into this that
that's fine I'm kind of springing this
on you it seems that the vitamin D piece
has had some favorable results where
compared to a placebo generally speaking
the correct level of vitamin D has a
generally protective effect it's not a
treatment for covid but it seems as
though what we suspected about vitamin D
that if your if your level is low you're
more susceptible to illness that seems
to have been confirmed right I mean that
that seems one of the early things we
learned
so I think there was a lot of
um there was a lot of conflicting data
on this as well there was encouraging
signs but
there was just a large study published
uh
I think within the last week and I have
the study on my to read list but I
haven't read it and
um it doesn't show any benefit oh it
does vitamin D you know yeah so it's a
negative result
um for vitamin D and is that for
supplementation generally or just
looking at if you're deficient versus
you're not you might be better or worse
off so this is where we get I wish I had
read the study right I haven't read this
study so I don't want to misspeak on
that fair but but that seems to be a
fundamental question I guess that should
be answered
yeah so in the case of vitamin D I think
the the argument had been
uh that perhaps a deficiency would have
been something to address but then that
that doesn't mean anything about
supplementation right so if you're if
you're not deficient then
supplementation wouldn't necessarily be
assumed to have any have any benefit and
in this case I honestly I haven't read
the study result so
um I I don't want to misrepresent uh you
teach in Singapore I'm curious if you
can kind of give us some insights as to
whether the entire media and social
media landscape around these discussions
is different there than in the United
States which which it has been
completely out of control in Rife with
misinformation and disinformation what's
the sort of feel there of these
discussions
uh in social media or the news media
either that you feel comfortable
commenting on
sure well I mean the news media is
pretty tame here
um and uh so that so there's not much in
in the news media in the social media
there's been some there's actually been
a pro
Ivermectin group and and as often
happens the fellow Travelers in this
tend to be anti-vaxx and so there's uh
they've been pro-living anti-vaxx
anti-mandate and and some of uh some of
them have gotten into legal trouble
um and that's they've used social media
telegram groups Facebook groups and so
on to uh to basically work
um to do their work and spread their
message and in fact in some sense that's
how I got into this because somebody had
been influenced by these groups and
asked me for help asked me to help her
understand these things and kind of
ultimately
she ended up getting a vaccine but it
took a while
well the YouTube channel is excellent
you really break these things down in a
way that is both detailed but also
accessible which I think is so important
right now when we talk about science
communication I want to suggest to
everybody in my audience check out Greg
Tucker Kellogg's YouTube channel Greg is
a biology professor at the National
University of Singapore really
appreciate your time today
well thanks very much David really nice
talking to you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
yesterday when we looked at some of the
things said by people who went to the
Michigan Trump rally over the weekend I
missed a clip and it's really like the
most important clip and so in a way it's
good because it won't get all mixed up
in a slurry of Insanity we'll just look
at this one clip um this is a video clip
of a woman who went to the Trump rally
over the weekend
and she has a really specific
and really complicated conspiracy theory
about election theft and she starts by
saying the election was stolen from
Trump that's not super unique there's
millions of these people who believe
that the election was stolen from Trump
but her explanation is so out there that
listen let's do this let's play the clip
try to listen specifically to each of
the points of the conspiracy and then
we'll talk about them all at once in a
moment the election I believe was stolen
but we know that space force has it all
Trump has all the all the information
it's going to be overturned what do you
think space force has
space force is a military branch of the
you know just like the army that you
know all the military and they literally
walk up here
they literally the night of the election
they literally watched the election be
stolen they know they Watermark the
ballots they know exactly what happened
with every ballot they know what fake
ballots all right they saw they knew the
election switches they know what
countries were involved they know they'd
followed the money they know what every
politician that's been paid off they
know there's um there was 260 000 269
000
sealed indictments but I think it might
even be up to 500 000 sealed indictments
and I believe that we're going to have
an emergency broadcast and the military
is going to come in with martial law
and we are going to be shown eight hours
on eight hours off of videos for seven
days the world and they're going to be
showing us taped
uh tribunals tape confessions
and the world is going to be awakened to
what's really going on with the Deep
state
the election was stolen okay well I mean
that part's common
and I understand what she's saying but
then the rest of it doesn't really make
sense space force and Trump
have all the information all right well
I I don't know why they would have
information but I still follow it it's
going to be overturned well no it's not
I mean listen we're at the next election
already and if Biden were removed for
any reason Kamala Harris becomes VP and
if she's removed then it's Nancy Pelosi
so it that doesn't really make any sense
at all she says the night of the
election space force watched the
election get stolen
what does that mean they watched it like
on TV or they watched it as an
institution she says space force
watermarked the ballots why would space
force do that space force is now
involved in like printing that doesn't
make any sense how would space force
Watermark ballots and then what would
they do with them after that so now I
guess because of the watermarking space
force knows everything including which
countries are involved which is really
like a wow kind of situation she says
politicians have been paid off in space
force knows about it and then it's
completely off the rails and she adds
that there were 269
000 sealed indictments 269
000 people were about to be indicted For
What and space force knew about it why
does space force know about it wouldn't
that be the justice department but maybe
I'm asking too many questions and then
the military would come in with martial
law after an emergency broadcast you
know that's like those beeps that you
hear like this is a test of the
emergency you know the thing they would
you they would do that for hours and
hours with eight hours on and eight
hours off of confessions and tribunals
conducted by whom and when I mean none
of it makes any sense and here's the
real question about this
is this actually let really I want to
hear what you really believe
is this actually a conspiracy theory
that this woman came up with and
understands or is this something that
she misheard or misunderstood and what I
mean by that is I will often get emails
from people
misunderstanding everything I say on
this show a couple weeks ago someone
wrote it and said David I would be
really interested in hearing about where
in Belgium your family is from I've
never said my family is from Belgium I
said I've been to Belgium I said I liked
it I said they have good chocolate I
never said my family's from Belgium
sometimes I say hey if you want a free
membership fill out a form on my website
people email me David I'm asking you to
give me a membership no uh I say I'm
from Argentina and people say wow you're
from Israel yeah okay so if even me
saying really simple stuff leads to this
level of misunderstanding maybe this
entire conspiracy theory is not even
really a conspiracy really a conspiracy
theory she heard from someone else maybe
she misheard it and misunderstood it
either way it's very very scary and I
don't see that turning around anytime
soon and I'm starting to get people mad
at me I mean
for a particular reason people have been
mad at me for a while I'm starting to
get people mad at me because they say
David you need to be proposing solutions
to this problem of radical trumpists I
don't have them guys I'm sorry what I
can tell you is if we want to do
one-on-one it can be hours days weeks to
deprogram someone that's hard to do at
the wholesale level so I don't know that
that's the solution
when it comes to forcing rapid kind of
cultural change
when rapid cultural change has been
forced in the past it's been dictators
it was you know the cultural revolution
in China it was it's bad so that doesn't
seem good I'm not an authoritarian so I
can't say that's the direction we should
go so I don't have an answer yeah fixing
education of course but
I I don't pretend to be the expert with
all the answers I am sort of at my wit's
end with how we deal with these people
and you may know just as much as I do
I'm I happen to be the guy with the mic
but we all need to work together to
figure that out hey this is really just
weird and it kind of epitomizes stuff
we've been talking about for a long time
I guess there was an event at Trump's
Mar-A-Lago and at the event
there were gay supporters of trump and I
don't want to focus on why there are gay
supporters of trump like obviously
it doesn't really make a lot of sense
although I don't really think Trump is
personally very homophobic or or at all
necessarily but I think he has chosen to
buy in I don't think Trump cares one way
or the other Trump cares about gay
people as much as he cares about anybody
else which is he doesn't he just doesn't
really care about people whether they're
gay or straight but he's certainly done
the homophobic transphobic politics
since deciding to run as a republican
Republican and getting pulled in to this
reactionary movement so in any case
there are gay Trump supporters some of
them were at a fundraiser in Florida and
Trump said to them you don't look gay
yeah let's look at the clip
thank you very much
[Laughter]
we did great with the game popular you
know this uh clearly Trump seems to
think gay people have to look a certain
way or that they do I don't know this
reminds me of as many of you if you only
there's people who have no idea what I
look like because they only listen to my
show they don't watch it uh I am I guess
what's considered white hispanic like
I'm from Argentina grew up uh uh
speaking Spanish as my first language
and then learned English and okay you
know so that's that's the deal and um
because I learned English early enough I
don't have an accent except when I say
certain words like nuclear
and people when they learn that I am
Hispanic by the definition of the U.S
census sometimes they I can tell they
don't even know they're doing it they
will reflexively go
oh you you don't look Hispanic at all
almost like they're saying oh I never
would have guessed you were sick you
don't you don't look sick at all like
it's a compliment that I don't look what
they believe Hispanic people look like
and I don't you know this is not like
the gravest Injustice I find it funny
the reaction that I sometimes get from
people and it's kind of a similar thing
from Trump oh you guys are gay oh you
don't look gay again as if that's a good
thing they don't conform to whatever
stereotype of gayness Trump would have
imagined uh and I guess you know when I
say when I said earlier I don't know
that Trump is that homophobic that's a
pretty homophobic idea actually if I do
say so myself but very strange times at
uh Trump's fundraisers and I expect
these to get wackier and wackier as the
2022 election comes forward because
Trump is he seems to be making an effort
to actually support the candidacies of
different people and in order to do that
you start to be around a lot of
different people and uh Trump doesn't
seem to know how to relate to a lot of
different types of people which is which
is a weird thing but apparently the gay
Trump supporters were not offended
they found it funny so that's that we
have a voicemail number that number is
219 to David P here's a voicemail with a
it's a it's an interesting question take
a listen David I just want to suggest
what would have happened if Pence had
followed through on what Trump wanted
him to do where do you think we would be
now thank you right so Trump wanted
Pence to overturn the election and Pence
said I can't do that I don't have the
power to do that constitutionally and
Pence was of course correct let's play
it out let's say Pence was willing to do
what Trump wanted him to do which is
when Arizona tries to say our delegates
vote for Joe our electors vote for Joe
Biden when Michigan tries to say
our electors vote for Joe Biden Mike
Pence what they wanted Pence to do was
to say nope
these are in dispute we are instead
going to let a different slate of
electors vote instead of seven
Republicans or how or seven Democrats or
however many it was from Arizona we're
going to let these seven Republicans
vote instead and they vote for Trump uh
it never would have worked
it never would have worked those
alternate slates of electors
they let's see how I can explain this
determining who the rightful electors
are is not something that goes from the
Senate from the house from the Senate
you know the House of Representatives
from the from Congress to the states the
states decide who are the electors and
send them to D.C
so
if Arizona
had seven Republicans get together and
say we are the electors which happened
it happened in Arizona
uh Mike Pence doesn't actually have the
right to recognize any other particular
people so it would have gone nowhere now
it would have caused chaos I do believe
that if Mike Pence tried
to do that it would not have worked Joe
Biden would still be president today but
it would have riled up some trumpists to
such a degree because they would have
gotten into their head that it was
possible for Pence to do it that the
riots likely would have been
dramatically worse and maybe would have
even lasted for days that's my sense let
me know what you think would have
happened if Pence tried to do it make
sure you were a member so that you get
access instantly to the bonus show world
famous award-winning bonus show awards
we give out sure but Awards nonetheless
sign up right now at joinpakman.com and
you can use the coupon code wow22 to
save big off of a member
foreign